Madison asks as an email marketer I say
email is not dead do you think email
will be more or less relevant in three
to five years Madison great question
three to five years it's always hard to
predict that way out but I'll get to
that part and we're actually to answer
this question I just want to give a huge
shout out to the vaynernation for
supporting this show I'm uh I'm really
enjoying it i was super bummed about
friday night so i apologize i think i
tweeted that i was going to have it and
let some people down i hate letting
people down email is definitely not dead
i would say that email right now I like
marketing in the year that we live in so
I would say right now that email is a
very killer app now our open rates at
ninety percent like I had in 1997
absolutely not but is it an own channel
that you control and don't have to be at
the mercy of all these other platforms
that you can market to your people for
sure I think we can't be naive to the
fact that Google made changes with Gmail
about a year ago feels like now are
within the year where we went to a
promotions tab I see stunwin shaking his
head Steve were you affected by the
promotions tab were you part of any
email lists that you noticed went there
oh yeah absolutely now here's the here's
the punch line question show me punch
line question here's the punch line
question do you feel that some of those
that got switched to the promotion tabs
you've actually fallen off because they
don't go to your native in feed and you
either unsubscribed or you just don't
pay attention to any more totally gone
yep probably five or six events that's
my concern so what's happening is do I
think email will matter three to five
years for sure I think it's in play it's
a channel it's not going anywhere do I
think it's dead absolutely not do I
think it'll be more or less valuable as
a marketing engine I will go with less
valuable in three to five years it will
still be very valuable because it's one
of the best channels but it will be less
valuable that whole marketers ruin
everything line that I use a lot that's
what this is all about platforms come
along they have value and then we mark
it against them and then consumers kind
of push off its cops and robbers it's
cat and mouse over and over and over
again and we're living in a process now
that we're into the second decade of
email being ruined by marketers oh crap
wait subscribe
I need subscriptions because I can't
push this many right hooks in social so
subscribe